what's that believe nation today I'm
going to talk about seven essential
tools that all entrepreneurs should know
about and as always guys if you hear a
point that really resonates with you
please leave it down in the comments
below put quotes around that so other
people can be inspired as well and also
writing it down helps you lock it in for
yourself to enjoy so I often get asked
by entrepreneurs what tools do you use
what are some of the most impactful
resourceful tools that you put into
practice every day to help you build
your business and what should I apply in
my company that helped me grow faster
and so today I'm going to share with you
my seven tools that I think every
entrepreneur should be aware of and
using in their company too number one is
a calendar and this is the most basic of
all the tools that I'm going to talk
about today a calendar whether you're
using your outlook whether you're using
your Google Calendar whether you're
using a physical calendar a calendar is
so so so so important but more important
than just having a calendar is sticking
to it and abiding by it how many times
do you set something in your calendar
not a meeting with somebody else I think
with meetings you're more likely to go
to it could you commit to somebody else
but you put something in your calendar
and then you don't stick to it you put
something down and say I'm gonna work on
my business in this time chunk and then
something comes up and you don't stick
to it
you don't keep it as a priority and so
one it's having the discipline and the
patience to actually stick to it and two
it's making the calendar that makes
sense and so every month on a small
scale and every quarter on a bigger
scale I'll look at my calendar I'll see
where I'm spending my time on different
activities and think is this the best
use of my time is there something else
that I want to work on and then if I add
that to my calendar what gets taken away
and so most days when I wake up I'm just
applying what I wrote down in mice
calendar it's just work mode grind mode
I'm not thinking high-level strategic
what should be in my calendar because if
you're thinking like that every day if
every day is just how am I gonna plan
how am I gonna plan you don't ever take
action we have to take action as an
entrepreneur so most days I'm waking up
and I'm just taking action and living
according to the calendar that I set up
for my
so and then once a month or once a
quarter I look at it and it's like hmm
you know that time there that's not
really being spent effectively and I
want to add this new thing in so I need
to find a spot for so let's shift things
around and so making a good calendar
that works for you works for your
schedule works for what you want to
accomplish with your goals and then
sticking to it is one of the most
important resources that you can use as
an entrepreneur
[Music]
number two is up work upward calm is a
website that freelancers from around the
world can sign up to and you can use
them to bid on your projects a lot of
times people think when they have to
hire somebody they need somebody local
and it needs to be somebody full-time or
you can get people highly talented
highly skilled who are working overseas
who will work part-time for you on a set
number of hours and will be a lot
cheaper than hiring somebody local to do
amazing amazing amazing work for you and
recognize you can't do this alone and so
having a team of people around you who
can help complement your weaknesses and
do amazing things for your company is
really important I think the hiring
process is broken for a lot of companies
I'm a big fan of bringing people on on a
trial basis letting them see what they
can do seen more in the results because
I don't think a job interview and a
resume really speaks to somebody's
results if you're hiring a video editor
as an example their ability to write a
resume and to do well in a job interview
has nothing to do with their ability to
actually make good videos and so I'd
much rather skip a lot of this stuff and
move to okay let's start working on
trial project and see what you can do in
a couple hours work I made a video
called the hiring process is broken I
recommend you go check that out because
it has a lot of those steps in a lot
more detail being able to bring on good
people from around the world who can
help you build your big mission and
achieve your goals in a cost-effective
way and on a part-time basis is such an
amazing resource for you and so I highly
recommend checking out upwork
[Music]
number three is 99designs this is
similar to upwork but just for design
and so what happens is you can create a
project that you need for your design
work whether it's a new logo and your
website designing banners Flyers
brochures business cards whatever it is
it needs to be designed if you are not a
designer yourself
you can put it up on 99designs they
recommend different pricing points and
people from around the world will bid on
it and they'll bid on it with designs
and so you can structure your contest so
that you only pay if you're getting a
design that you actually like and so
people will bid on it they'll submit
designs you give feedback you go back
and forth until you get something that
you love and say yes that's it
I think a lot of times the way that we
hire designers can also be broken
typically it's you look at a portfolio
and say well here's what we've done in
the past it doesn't mean that I'm gonna
get something good just because you've
done this kind of work in the past it
doesn't mean that what you're gonna give
me is gonna be amazing
the best way to figure it out is to
actually get involved in a project and
start doing it the challenge of hiring
somebody locally is you pick one person
it's going to be expensive and you don't
know if you're gonna get a great result
where with a website like 99 designs you
get people from around the world
you'll get dozens to hundreds of designs
and you can tweak and go back and forth
until you get the one you actually
actually actually love and want to use
in your business and so another great
tool to use I highly recommend for any
design work 99 designs
[Music]
the number for resources YouTube we're
all here watching on YouTube and it's no
surprise for me it's both as a creator
and then also as a resource I think if
you're a creator you have a chance to
tell your story to promote your business
to talk about you know behind the scenes
why you started this how you do certain
things I think every entrepreneur should
at least consider being on YouTube as a
part of their business whether YouTube
becomes your business or it's just a
funnel for your business you know for my
company for Evan Carmichael you know
incorporated a lot of the opportunities
that I get from my company come through
the YouTube channel for trial dance
salsa we're posting videos every week on
our YouTube channel and it helps drive
students more like the model is not
revenue off of YouTube but students
coming to the class because now they're
aware of what we're doing I think it's a
fantastic marketing opportunity for any
entrepreneur because so many people are
on YouTube and people want to know your
story your competitive advantage as an
entrepreneur is your story the way you
beat the big guys in your industry is
not going to be on price it's not gonna
be on reputation it's gonna be on your
story I feel connected to you I feel
like you just care more and you can't
really communicate care more if you have
a boring website and the easy way to do
is get in front of a camera and just
talk you don't have to be great and you
don't need to have fantastic gear most
important thing is the message that I
feel the passion and the connection to
you and why you started this business so
that's from the creator side I think
from a learning point of view it's also
really helpful a lot of the best
learning that I've received in my life
has come from my own YouTube channel I
mean it's why I started my youtube
channel I wanted to learn as well for
myself I wanted to study these famous
entrepreneurs and learn from them
because I didn't have connections to
famous entrepreneurs because nobody in
my family who was a successful
entrepreneur and so I wanted to hang
around these people I knew it was
important I didn't know how to go out
and do it so I thought I'm gonna I'm
gonna make a YouTube channel better and
every time we profile a famous
entrepreneur I review the videos I
review the content I only put it up
because I have learned something from
these videos and it's been the single
greatest source of education that has
helped me as an entrepreneur is by
watching my own videos every day and so
I think whether you're watching my
videos or whether you're trying to
a certain skill u2 was a fantastic free
resource that wasn't available you know
in the past I wish I had this when I was
going through high school because it
could dramatically shortcut your path to
learning something as well as connect
you to people who actually know what
they're talking about connect you to
experts in certain fields that before
you would have no access to so I highly
recommend whatever you want to learn
somebody's made a youtube video about it
[Music]
my number five resource for
entrepreneurs is snapchat Facebook and
Instagram I think these are really
important tools to again help you tell
your story I think entrepreneurs need to
learn how to tell their story better I
think YouTube typically people look at
as a more polished resource so you know
you make a video and there's editing
involved in it it's longer form where if
you just want to film from your phone
you want to get better practice more
experience you can get on snapchat you
can get on Instagram you can do the
stories you can do Facebook with the
stories now all three platforms allow
you to make really informal videos it's
expected to be informal it's expected
when you do snapchat that people are
coming from their phone and it's
expected to be more raw it doesn't need
to be produced it doesn't need to be
edited and so it's a great tool to help
you become a better storyteller to help
get your message out there more and the
good news is for some of you the stuff
that you create expires in 24 hours I'm
not a huge fan of it because I want the
stuff that I make to live forever when I
put love into something into these
videos I wanted to live forever I want
my grandkids to watch this and learn
from it and apply it to their life and
their business I want to build a legacy
but if you're nervous and you're worried
and you're not sure how good you're
gonna be and you don't want everybody to
see it and to live forever
then get on snapchat and get on
Instagram stories because the stories
disappear in 24 hours when I took over
trying to dance salsa
I wanted Alex who's helping me run the
company to get good at storytelling he
had zero experience zero practice in
this and so I wanted to make youtube
videos with him but I wanted him to
develop the experience and practicing it
better and so every day he's on snapchat
posting recommended three snaps per day
to improve his own skills so yes Phil
the following and he's getting people
watching him every single day now and
people emailing him people talking
him who come into class and say I saw
your sad that was really good
he's involving people in the snaps the
most important part is to improve your
storytelling in a really low risk way if
nobody watches it at the start it
doesn't matter if you make a big mistake
you don't even have to post it but if
you do doesn't matter because it's gonna
disappear in 24 hours and so it's a
great way to know that your customers
are here your customers are on those
platforms storytelling is going to be
your competitive advantage those
platforms are where the big companies
aren't yet and so your ability to tell
your story in a meaningful way on the
platforms that exist that your customers
are in where the big companies aren't
yet that's an easy chance for you to win
as an entrepreneur and how they
recommend getting involved and improving
your skills the number six resource for
entrepreneurs is finding your one word
this may sound a little self-serving but
I wrote the book and we have the concept
in the philosophy behind it because it's
so incredibly important for
entrepreneurs when I discovered what my
one word was which was believe
everything I touched that was around
believe instantly took off and I didn't
just go all-in on believe in my business
I tested it I tested on my newsletter
and the first newsletter was the best
newsletter that I had ever put out
I tested on my videos and the first
belief video was at that time the best
video that I ever put out you know got a
hundred thousand views in the first
month where all my other videos the best
video took a year to get a hundred
thousand views this happened in the
first month and now has over two million
views everything I touched the round
believe did better I hired people better
I made better content I communicated my
message better I got more website
traffic my YouTube videos to everything
everything I did became better now this
was just me and so I thought ok let's
apply this other people as other
entrepreneurs that I connected with I
shared this philosophy and shared this
story with they discovered their one
words as they applied it to their
business they did better they got more
customers they got more word-of-mouth
they had an easier message that people
connected with and wanted to spread for
them they got better employees they got
an investment into their company and so
it's such an important tool to know what
you staying for to understand the single
most important core value that you have
and then inject that into your business
and make every single important decision
through the lens of your
were makes all the difference in the
world and can really catapult your
business a success so highly recommend
checking it out and the number seven
essential tool for entrepreneurs this is
a mind twist is just your
resourcefulness I think a lot of people
put too much stock into tools I think a
lot of people expect the tools to save
them the tools will not save you if you
are an unorganized person it doesn't
matter what tool you use Evernote
OneNote Gmail a notebook
whatever calendar system like none of
the tools will save you if you have bad
habits and you need to have the habit of
being resourceful the most important
tool that you can ever have is right
here is you is your mindset is your
belief system and I think a lot of times
people always blame the tools I'm not
more successful because I don't have the
right tools or because I don't have the
budget to do it I'm not a big youtuber
because I don't have the right camera or
not the right lighting or gear or
editing software blah blah blah none of
that stuff matters their incremental
growth yes it can help you but much more
important is you the most important
ingredient in being an entrepreneur in
this context is just your
resourcefulness it's never about how
many resources you have it's about how
resourceful you are you will never have
enough resources you'll never have
enough resources to do the big thing you
want to do there always be something
else that you want to get and shoot for
and always another excuse or reason to
pin it on why you're not more successful
and as long as you're constantly blaming
those things blaming the tools or your
bad tools then you're never gonna get to
where you need to go so the most
important tool of all of all for
entrepreneurs is your resourcefulness so
thank you guys so much for watching I'd
love to know what did you think of this
video which of the seven tools was your
favorite and why is there an 8 9 10 that
you want to add on the list as well
leave it down in the comments below I
would love to hear from you I also want
to give a quick shout out to Frodo thank
you so much for picking up a copy of my
book your one word and making that
awesome video as well on your channel I
really really really appreciate your
support and I'm really glad you enjoyed
the book as well so thank you guys so
much for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever you're one where it is much
love I'll see you soon